they came for him in the early hours of
the morning I de ningun was led from his
home by the police he's not the first
Turkish journalist to be arrested in
this way I Dean Abby as the 75 year old
newspaper man as respectfully called is
a good friend and conversation partner
for us German journalists in Istanbul
I'm very worried about him he's never
tired of explaining and commenting on
Turkish politics for us like he did this
July after the failed coup and always
with a touch of humor maybe meet you
this is the first coup that hasn't
landed me in jail on November first 18
innings column in the Turkish daily
newspaper Juliette was blank the public
prosecutor claims that engines writings
support terrorism we've only ever heard
him call for peace and reconciliation in
Turkey I encounter an angry crowd in
front of jhamora its building engine was
one of 13 leading journalists for the
paper who were arrested every day
innocent people are thrown in jail
enough is enough Jemaah react is one of
the last Turkish newspapers that
criticizes heroines government
supporters guard the entrance day and
night to discourage the police from
arresting even more of the staff this is
the office where Indian writes his
columns he's been writing for Germany
and for 25 years though there have been
interruptions the remaining editorial
staff is working on a new edition in the
next room the mood is glum and the
police are waiting outside not far away
I meet up with engines wife or your ba
da and we wonder what we can do for him
madara's known beyond turkeys boundaries
as an author her novels have been
translated into German and into English
we browsed through the bookshelves the
romanji I'm currently working on a novel
but I'm so preoccupied with worry that I
can't write a single line is earlier the
couple is braved hard times together
after the military coup of 1980 by
Darlene had to flee Turkey they lived in
exile in Germany for 12 years we're in
Game drove a taxi to support the family
now the political situation in Turkey is
similar to the way it was back then
Monmouth on the shimla by half German as
well as Turkish citizenship but go into
exile again at our age we'd rather go to
prison
life on the streets of Istanbul goes on
as usual but the country is being put to
the test and gain is repeatedly warned
against the danger of civil war that
angered the Erawan government and even
after three days none of us is permitted
to speak to him this is t24 an
independent news portal whose website
two million people visit every day the
internet is the last refuge for
journalists who have lost their jobs
like Dogon a keen he tells me about
iodine in games contribution how bad
need exact he is a perfectionist when it
comes to language he double-checks
everything before it's published we've
all learned a lot from him I've never
met anyone with such firm convictions
that will give him the strength to get
through this arrest this is the
notorious police headquarters of
Istanbul in Guinea and his colleagues
are being held here in the
anti-terrorism section finally after
five days we get good news and gain is
being released due to his age and the
state of his health mr. finishes I was
treated decently but I've never seen
such a trumped-up indictment we will not
bow to this pressure the next morning I
meet with engine at drum holding its
office he has to stand in for
editor-in-chief Moritz a bunch o who's
still in jail I'm uh looking awesome mmm
it in him I'm doing ok but my heart is
with my colleagues who are still
imprisoned we don't know whether Jim
hood yet will survive but I told my
young colleagues don't ask what tomorrow
brings produce a good paper today yes or
mean it's our newspaper mundo gustaria
puse Museum gustan is it
that's all the time he has for me he has
to go back to planning tomorrow's
edition which may be the last issue of
Jim wouldn't kill dog since our brother
I Dean has returned we feel stronger
again we're happy now will produce a
good newspaper miss Eileen ending once
said that in 50 years he survived three
coos and three stays in prison one thing
is clear he has no intention of giving
up